during yesterday's pathetic
campaign launch rally for Nikki Haley's
2024 Republican primary run
she did say one thing that's really
funny which is she demanded a cognitive
test for any candidate that's over 75
years old it just so happens that Donald
Trump is 76 years old now I I think
she's only talking about this overtly
when it comes to Joe Biden but it's a
pretty interesting way to also draw a
distinction with the guy she's running
against in the primary take a listen to
this
[Applause]
and mandatory mental competency tests
for politicians over 75 years old
now I love this because
obviously the big meaning of it is Joe
Biden is 80 and the Wright loves to talk
about that and one of the main arguments
that Nikki Haley is making in this just
nascent
primary campaign is that she's younger
that she is from a different generation
but we all of course know that Trump's
brain has glitched very badly over the
last six years and there are real
questions about Trump and cognitive
tests as well and Trump would also be
subject to one so I believe that
although the
of official meaning of this cognitive
test thing is a signal about Biden you
all know that Nikki Haley is also using
it to talk about Trump I don't know
whether the people in her audience
realize that which makes it particularly
funny now it the fact remains that she
can talk about cognitive tests all she
wants and whether 80 year old Biden or
76 year old Trump who would be 82 and 78
at the time of the next uh inauguration
I think roughly
um she can talk about that all she wants
she's still drawn absolutely no policy
distinction from Donald Trump and in
order to face Joe Biden she first needs
to win the Republican primary and at
this point in time it's not clear what
her argument is for why anybody should
vote for her other than I'm younger than
Trump maybe that resonates with the
Republican party at this point I don't
know it's going to be a real question my
guess is that by Monday maybe by Tuesday
we will have some polling in the
Republican primary that is from after
Nikki Haley's announcement she went in
polling three percent as a non-candidate
we'll see where she ends up Monday
Tuesday
one of our sponsors today is fume fume
is on a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume
far too many of us including ones that
harm our health fume is a natural
diffusive device that uses plants and
Behavioral Science to trade out your
negative habit for a positive one fume
is not a vape it's a non-electronic
device designed to transform your
negative habits instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fume uses cores infused with
plants like peppermint and cinnamon for
delicious natural flavors fumes new
version 2 model is Snappy and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap that's fun to fidget
with its fume's goal to make switching
easy or even enjoyable they have
thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below